Leyden is with us in Phoenix highlight
and how are you I'm good are you deaf
better than I deserve what's up yeah
there's one thank you for taking my call
basically my topic though is a student
loan debt as of right now I'm about
$35,000 and the whole of my student
loans the issue I'm having it is just
I'm slightly bitter about paying them
back is I went to ITT Tech I don't know
if you're up-to-date on what happened
with that school does that one get
closed yes the feds cut off funding to
ITT Tech and then it was pretty much the
next day they closed doors completely I
mean there were students that work nine
days away from graduating and they just
closed the doors on them yeah my issue
is I was about oh is all of your student
loan debt from an RTT tech attendance
yeah so half of it is through FAFSA and
the other half was through the school
which I'm assuming I don't have to pay
anymore all right you don't know about
all that
well there's a federal law that says
when a school closes that they can't
charge you for that and so if you have a
debt to ITT it is no longer valid you'll
have to check that out with your
attorney and I think there's a student
loan forgiveness on federal student
loans on them too I want you to check
that though I'm not sure it's on that
yeah I think you may go ahead fight your
way through all of this and be debt-free
yeah and that the issue I'm having is
getting the right information too
because there is forgiveness unevenness
government loans through them but you
had to have been attending or attending
within 90 days of them closing I managed
to get out much earlier and I actually
thought I was being very smart by doing
that cuz I've realized how bad I was
getting ripped off so I stopped
attending about a year and a half before
they closed down but now I'm not
forgiving on anything well what I
thought was the smart choice beforehand
actually if I was still attending I'd be
completely forgiven well I might push
back on that and I might use an attorney
to do so okay and that's that was kind
of my next question here it's nothing
I'd I mean it's worth $35,000 so I'm
probably gonna be willing to pay a
little bit of an attorney fee for
someone in that area to see if they can
help you though the attorney we direct
you towards on collections issue you can
find them at collection bully calm
collection bully calm and I think the
attorneys on the other end of that they
usually work with collectors that have
violated the Federal Fair Debt
Collection Practices Act and work to
have your debt forgiven under those
circumstances this is a little different
but I suspect they will know the
statutes and if there's a any kind of a
way they can push back on this I don't
know if there is or not but I think it's
worth messing with certainly the ITT
debt but even possibly the federal
federally insured debt it's something I
would definitely struggle I'm with you
I'd struggle to pay that one but um the
federal one if you cannot get it
forgiven you're going to pay it they
will stay with you for freaking ever
they'll be with you for the rest of your
life and so yeah the lesson for the rest
of you listening is don't take out
student loan debt both calls the last
two calls both of them just don't take
out you can't do yeah yes you can you go
someplace you can afford you work the
extra you work extra and you go
someplace you can afford and you study
something that's actually going to cause
your income to go up in the marketplace
as a result of studying it yes you can
people do it all the time there has to
be a decision that you make this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Music]